thank you everyone and hi I'm Mahan
I'm from Spotify and I'm not gonna talk
about prophet and God actually that's a
tool I'm just talking about
timeseriesforecasting so I'm just gonna
dive into some background that what I
like what is Spotify what we are doing
and then how we scale our models and
then like specifics especially how we
are going to scale a prophet as one of
the tool that Facebook built in their
projects so some background
I'm data engineer and software engineer
so three years on Spotify forecasting
team and we are like using so many tools
like like from spark CEO if you've heard
about CEO like dataflow and basically we
were like hungry person on Google Cloud
and also I used to be like me first part
of I used to be a Hadoop user like
basically everything on Hadoop and HDFS
so this is more like an engineering talk
is not like a like data science type I
would say it's more like engineering and
scaling and like tools and like some
stats about Spotify and also this is
retrieved like from our like a company
like a public page so you can also see
more more details about that
so some stats we have like 100 millions
subscribers applause so 270 million
monthly active users like 15 15 million
songs three billion playlists and 79
markets so you can see that like pretty
much everywhere around the globe so what
we do in the forecasting team so we are
like a team of maybe like 15 up around
15 people like in three different
locations basically in Stockholm and New
York so what we do is we do pretty much
forecast like pretty much most of the
matrix that we get like streams monthly
active users ads inventory and so forth
so like like imagine stream is like if
somebody listens to music or some people
like
how they're gonna how much they're going
to listen and let how many seconds how
many minutes and what's gonna happen in
the next two years so we have a 10 K
time series to forecast because usually
when we talk about a forecasting time
series it's like we have a we have one
time series and we try to forecast that
and we try to get unit and we will be
super happy but when it comes to 10 K
time series is not that simple to
forecast so this is one of our biggest
challenge so we usually forecast two
years ahead
so sometimes we also for test five years
so it's pretty tricky with all the
markets and that you all work in
different businesses you know that how
tricky it is that you try to kind of
forecast or predict the next two years
and also we forecast like officially we
like send our reports every at the end
of every quarter but actually we
forecast every day so I mean the amount
of complexity and resources that we use
we use it every day but then like we
just send the reports our forecast for
the next two years or five years like
like May fourth four times here so but
still is every day so like let's just
talk about some like basic basic kind
kind of informations about what is like
time series and what we do so time
series as everybody knows is like you
have data based on time in order in time
order so this time series so this is the
most famous one this is like Bitcoin so
then everybody knows Bitcoin so I mean
this is super hard to forecast so don't
don't do this because you're gonna fail
because this is there is no logic on
forecasting this one which I tried I
failed so and then this is like one time
series just imagine you have 10k of
these and imagine you wanna forecast
like like ten thousands of these these
time series and then what what is profit
profit is a tool that is built by fair
face we're gonna know maybe three years
ago and it got open source like two or
three years ago so we started to use
that right in combination with our other
models so like this is
the only model we have we have many
models we have retention coordination
model for forecasting our users and
monthly active users so this is one of
the tool and I want it to be super
specific that's why I put this name and
just to show how we are doing but the
whole talk is about pretty much how to
skate any model is not specific to
profit but since this was more cool to
present so for especially with time
series and I put this one and it's
available in Python and or so like
here's a PI data and actually I'm like a
Java developer Scala developer but I've
noticed that python is there is
something different is a new king in
this world these days because everybody
tries to write their complex model and
everything is on Python these days so
it's super nice to have and there is one
also a good point about properties if
you try it if you have tried to forecast
time series in the past it is complex
you need to know a lot of things but
profit is kind of a blackboard it's not
a black box we can see what is happening
but it's easy with just default
parameters you try to forecast something
so this is this is super important
imagine a black path we send some data
you get a result so is often as accurate
as if some kind of advanced like models
how they do that this is almost accurate
I would say in in most cases so it is
good so you don't need to know lot a lot
of logics in order to forecast time
series and then what else do we have
there are a lot of distributed tools
that we use as par 5 but we chose spark
on GCP on Google Cloud 4 for this case
because there was a the previous talk
was I've heard about a sage maker a for
Amazon is like how to scale or how to
distribute a paralyze the job so I'm
gonna talk about why we chose spark and
how we can benefit from spark in this
specific case so like the spark is there
is a service like on Google cloud a data
product we have spark as a service on
that with Hadoop so it is super fast it
is very easy to to
spin up the clusters and when I say fast
is even super fast to create ephemeral
clusters and try to destroy it so you
don't need to have a running spark
running spark class that were running
Hadoop cluster you just spin up spin up
the cluster quickly you run your job and
then the cluster will be gone so he's
fully managed and cost-effective as I
said so it is it is cheap just imagine
for every job you don't have like I
don't know because we used to have 2,500
nodes of Hadoop cluster like two years
ago so imagine this big cluster that is
running every day but we don't have it
anymore
so if just spin up a cluster super
quickly in four minutes five minutes you
run your job and then the job is under
the whole nodes will be gone so it's
super cost-effective and why python is a
new team in this in this era you know
there are so many tools as I said they
are written in Python and profit is also
in Python pi spark spark is a super
mature product so you can use power in
pretty much all a cloud vendors you can
use it like on Prem pretty much
everywhere on your machine locally so
imagine spark has Python our tools are
Python profitless Python we can quickly
install a packages on the enterprise
pretty much all the libraries that we
have access to through peep or Conda or
or anything so it's super easy to spin
up install the application install the
libraries and get they get the benefit
of any library on spark on cloud so now
I just talked about the background what
what we are using and then how we now
I'm going to talk about how we are going
to mix all of this together in order to
scale a model so first just let's talk
about one forecast this is like the
example that I just talked about Bitcoin
imagine if we have these time series so
there are some actual imagine this is
the this is any any time series with
properties
super easy you put it into the model and
then you have some forecasted results
and then you will be happy this dotted
red line is the forecasted results so
how long it takes because this is not
like a neural network like advanced
analytics or is like this is not like if
you run a model it takes like two days
to run this takes a couple of minutes to
few minutes a couple of seconds to few
minutes so this is super fast on profit
and the run time is also based on how
much data you're gonna have and what are
the settings that you have so I would
say in five minutes even sometimes in
ten minutes you get a result so it's not
a big deal you can run it in your
machine and everybody's happy and this
is what we started in the beginning so
we had to time switch to forecast
everybody was running in their machine
on some Python darker based tools that
we have we were happy
but when we wanted to run multiple of
these models because usually it's like
this is super easy we just iterate we
say okay we have hundred hundred time
series to run and then we a create a for
loop usually and then we run it and then
when we try to do this which we didn't
it would have taken two days if you
wanted to run all of this and this is
impossible because as I said we want to
run all of these forecasts every day
every single day single day and we don't
want to wait for like two days in order
to have a results and imagine if we if
we have two at week if you had if we
have to tune or something else so this
is this is pretty impossible so
sequentially we cannot run any model in
this way and since SPARC is a super easy
tool and then is like there are a lot of
documentation is is easy to kind of use
park with anything else so we started to
use a profit or any model with spark by
creating a framework so what happens is
like this is like a typical spark I
don't know if anybody used spark before
if you just raise your hand oh nice
everybody uses so then I don't need to
maybe discuss about the details of small
but it's a pretty simple so if you have
a as I showed you if you have this model
with inputs and outputs so we pretty
much distributed in spark executors and
then each like each code each each model
will be kind of as a will be run as a
task and spark and you can just spin up
a cluster with any number of nodes with
any number of cores with how much memory
you want and then you are going to scale
this so like 10k that we talked about it
if you if I wanted to run it
sequentially it would have taken two
days but in the way that we run on SPARC
it takes like 30 minutes so it's like
super efficient just imagine if like
every 30 minutes even I can test it like
100 times a day because this is super
easy if I want to do that and one more
thing for SPARC if because I don't want
to forget this one and one of the good
point of spark is SPARC is not just to
distribute your logic it's not just to
scale your logic in this way because
there are other tools they can do that
also you need some extra aggregation
later on or maybe some data crunching in
the beginning so we can take the benefit
of all of this together so this is not
just like any services on cloud that you
give your code and then it will run your
code like many many times because how
about the aggregation how about the
cleanup are you gonna run a Python local
Python code on your laptop in order to
clean up your job like if you get a like
the data from like data warehouse or
somewhere or you are going to do that on
spark if the data is so big like we have
some cases that maybe each partition or
each day is like 2 terabytes so I cannot
just run like I don't know maybe 200
terabytes on my on my laptop so that's
impossible
but with support we can do that so what
did we really do so we created an
in-house tool you know
to do all of these things together so
this is the what this tool is doing is
trying to distribute or scale any model
specifically profit as I said so this is
like pretty much plug and play so here a
lot of people they know spark or they
use it so but this this this code is you
don't really need the spark knowledge so
if you have your model like pure Python
pure like data frame whatever you want
to use if you plug it into this
framework this framework will distribute
it you don't need to care about the
under the hood like what is happening
with spoil what is tasked what is
executors how driver can handle all of
this what you need to care about is your
your data frame or Python the air frame
even you don't need to care about spa
data frame because everything will be
translated back and forth so you don't
you don't need to care about you and how
you how you run that so you how this
will be run it will be run by the
permutation of the your parameters what
does it mean
so if imagine if you have some
parameters like country I'm not talking
about the hyper parameter I'm talking
about any parameter it could be country
it could be City it could be like some
settings in your logic imagine if you
create a primitive permutation if you
want to mix all of these in order to run
maybe pancake so this is a tool that can
really help you to do that and later on
as you can see here so you are going to
aggregate on spark you don't need to
aggregate somewhere else
you don't need to run in parallel push
into a data warehouse and do the rest on
data warehouse because then then what's
the point let's have all the code
together in in one place and also this
is fully integrated with bigquery with
pretty much all the tools on GUI cloud
and Google Cloud Storage so on also
bigquery is a kind of a data warehouse
tool on Google cloud this is specific
for a good cloud so it was a little bit
hard in the beginning in in order to
integrate like spark with bigquery there
were some issues but so now this tool is
completely working with all of this
together
and I just talked about it again some
tools and then what but what really
happens in order to scale our logic so
here on top as I said there is a model
you can just say profit or any other
model so training data like any other
model we have some parameters as I said
this is not like a typical hyper
parameter we are talking about so we
have sets of parameters and then we
forecast with profit as I said like
maybe it takes one minute to run so not
a big deal
so the framework that we created so you
pretty much plot the model or profit
into our framework and then you have a
sets of parameters now so you
I mean before you had a one set of
parameter and you have now sets of
parameters and then it will run all of
them together then you can do something
a grenade and it push the data back into
some storage it could be movie a cloud
storage or bigquery so then you have all
the forecasts ready so I'm just going to
talk about a little bit of tuning so
this is I'm not gonna dive into how we
tune or how scoring happens so this is
more about the engineering side so
imagine I just talked about 10 10 K
forecasts imagine if you want to tune
like one of them or all of them so then
tuning is gonna be super kind of
time-consuming and it's going to be
super costly so then basically how we
are going to do tuning so as I said in
the beginning occasionally profit is
good if you just use the default
settings profit is super good you don't
need to really tune but what if there
are some cases that you have to tune
because there is no other way you have
to tune and this this is going to happen
under the hood on sport so imagine to
forecast now red and green so we are not
going to talk about the 10k just two of
them so this is the way how the job will
be distributed on spark
so like forecast one
with the first set of parameter it will
end up here and then some of them end up
in another server or another executor
and so forth so here we have two nodes
or two servers imagine if we have 50
servers how is gonna be how complex is
going to be and then everything we try
to tune it I'm not going to say how the
tuning is happening now I'm just saying
that we can say if we are going to
forecast for for England so England can
have one forecast and can have like
hundred forecast and if hundred forecast
if we are going to tune all of them is
going to be maybe like 20,000 forecasts
just for England so it's going to be too
much so this is how scaling is happening
on smart with tuning so this this is
also one of the example like how how the
Tool Works imagine like four countries
UK Sweden Italy and us and these are
like four parameters that we are gonna
I'm gonna show it in this middle in this
heart and then imagine another set of
parameters like change point is
something on profit so you can have
these this column you can have hundreds
of these and imagine all of these
combinations together if you try to
multiply all of this together imagine
maybe for one forecast and in order to
tune maybe you will have maybe 50,000
combinations so one forecast 50,000
combinations and we have 10k forecast so
this is pretty much impossible if you
want to do all of this together and I
just said about parallel tuning so
parlor tuning was we blindly run
everything so when when I said this red
one I'm not gonna kind of this is not
like really Bayesian optimization or any
other optimization this is like brute
force and try to run whatever we just
talked about sorry whatever whatever I
said so he's going to brute force and in
the end we are gonna try to score and we
are gonna say that okay 100 of the
rounds that
hat so they are not important let's
stick into maybe 20 of them or we don't
need to really brute force so for each
run so we also integrated some like
open-source bayesian optimizations so
what we do is instead of running like
magic for forecast one instead of
running like forecast 100 times with
different parameters we try to tune and
optimize in one task so now one task can
take longer but is then you don't need
to really brute force like pretty much
all the possibilities which is
impossible so this is the smaller way in
order to tune 10k forecasts and then how
we do that so I just showed you here so
we have to hard code like what are the
prior scales or what are the settings or
parameters that we have because we have
to know in the beginning how many
permutations do we have but when this
tool went with if we try to use any kind
of advanced optimizations imagine
Bayesian optimization then now we can
even be more advanced and we can also
use what is it we can use ranges in
order to in order to tune so now instead
of having like zero point five six seven
eight which is like four numbers so we
are going to have a range from 0.5 to
0.8 so based on our logic and based on
and based on the tuning so then this
will kind of this automatically will be
set every time that we try to tune so
it's gonna be like this first time there
are some like predefined parameters then
it tries to tune and then second time
and then we can say ok let's run it ten
times and then that's that's enough but
still we don't have to forecast we have
10k also there are like whatever I just
talked about there are some like
interesting effects like the and also
the importance of why we really try to
do this to try to make these complex
infra for for handling
forecast because as I said if you run in
your machine it takes some time if you
run on one server it takes some time but
if you really want to run everything
together it takes forever so how we run
with one node imagine a node with like
sixteen virtual CPUs and 60 gigabyte of
memory so this is this is a pretty big
node and usually we run with 50 nodes so
50 nodes 800 virtual CPUs and 3 terabyte
of memory so every time we spin up this
node we run all the job and then we
delete the node so Google Cloud in this
case is super amazing because this huge
node it this huge cluster it will take 4
minutes sometimes even maybe less so
imagine like you just wait 4 minutes and
later on you have a huge cluster and you
can just run any any job on that
so 10k forecast as I said so it will
take 30 minutes on this huge cluster so
this is this is pretty impressive and
the most kind of important fact is the
cost is around $5 so imagine one job
with this complexity with all of these
number of runs if it takes like if it
just costs $5 is way more cheaper than
if you wanted to have a shared Hadoop
cluster or something shared that you
don't really get the capacity usually
because nobody gives you 100 CPUs on a
Hadoop cluster or somewhere else because
that that is impossible but here you are
pretty flexible to create any number of
nodes with any number of kind of with
like any amount of memory so how much
time do I have
yes so and then we had a lot of
challenges the first challenge was
basically because we we wanted to
convince people at Spotify and still we
have this challenge and also we wanted
to convince that this this kind of
framework worth to have it not just for
our case for other models and ok
because the problem is and we are we are
using a lecture or data flow that's the
this is more or less the same as sport
but it's like darker base and it's like
it's with Auto scales so it's super nice
so we have to we had to do it on another
tool there were a lot of reasons because
also data flow you can support Python
but SPARC maturity and there were like
other reasons that we chose part and one
of the one of the biggest reasonable was
like what I asked from here like 80% of
the people they use part it was super
easy we didn't need to ask from data
scientist because our team is basically
the other scientists we didn't need to
ask them to learn another language or
another tool because SPARC is is it is a
de facto and another challenge that we
had was it is still we have is not
efficient or is not really possible to
treat you a 10k forecast so we said that
we can just every on each forecast so we
can tune it as much as possible so we
can do even more advanced logics we can
even add more data but but this is not
even really possible because we really
need to spit out 10k forecast so we
cannot use so we have to be selective
for some of them that we know that they
are more tricky and then we have to tune
that so even with this complex
infrastructure that is not possible
also we had some cases that we we were
kind of really reaching the limit so we
were trying to tune and forecast 500k so
10k like we were like having had we had
like 50 times more kind of forecast runs
so at that limit we noticed that like
things were not going in the right way
so sometimes imagine that the cluster
even was more expensive and we had a
double of number of nodes and then it
was taking like three hours and after
three hours everything was fine then we
went to the big quarry there was no
result so then we were
checking all the logs on google cloud we
didn't find anything
so this was one of the problem that like
randomly happened so we're gonna talk
more with Google engineers maybe if we
find out what is really happening
because there are different steps there
is a like step on how we run on data
product there is another step how we
push the data into Google Cloud Storage
there is a third step how we push data
from Google Cloud Storage to be Korean
so we had these challenges that if
something sometimes kind of runs
randomly our success like randomly it
will be successful so that's gonna be
tricky so that was the limit that we had
so we are we are trying to solve but
it's not a big deal and also testing
locally because smart as like like
everybody knows sport we can just really
run and test locally so that was a
benefit for us so we recruited we are
creating our model so we are trying to
test it locally so we just test it with
like some trades on locally and then we
are gonna push it and with continuous
delivery and pretty much add all the
fancy words that these days people use
we build and then we push into
production
then we schedule and everything will be
wrong but every now and then we run into
issue it could be data quality it could
be any other any other problem that
maybe there are some maybe there is a
new market that we don't have enough
data so profit cannot forecast that so
sometimes we run into some issues that
locally it is not possible so then we
really have to run it on a cluster we
have to run it for all the combinations
in order to find out what is happening
so as the previous speaker was talking
so logging is super important and we
also try to like as much as possible but
don't try to log your data because if
you make a mistake like what what I did
so I try to light some of the some of my
like test data so I just try to kind of
multiply some like random data and then
I try to log and then my computer broke
and that's okay so then is good at to
try to test locally if you break
something then you are not gonna do that
because it's gonna be super costly and
I'm not a problem that we had so this is
this is a bit tricky because everybody
knows that spark creates files
it wasn't on HDFS or pretty much
everywhere so spark if you have a lot of
tasks or executors it creates files and
then these files will end up server so
if you have if you run the code in this
way that you have so many small tasks
each task create a small file because
maybe kilobytes of files and then spark
in the end will create maybe 100,000
hundred thousand files which is
impossible even to push into anywhere
either like Derrick Google Cloud storage
or Hadoop or bigquery so then now we
have to do some cool list and we have to
merge the data together on spark and if
the data is too much sometimes this is
this is tricky so now we want to be more
smart to find a way in order to merge
this data like we need to find how
efficient we can measure it on spark and
then offload the data into some
somewhere else so this was also one of
our challenge and thank you and I have
one more thing because I have I have
time now so I just wanted to have this
one in the end so so this is this is
pretty much the text tag we have this is
not about this tag is like about our
tooling in our team so she o is our data
ingestion it's like when we are talking
about terabytes of data so and also like
since all the pipeline's that everything
is kind of we have some standard tools
and kind of codes and like pretty much
everything so she'll we do the main
ingestion and she'll so we don't do that
on smart and she o is the scholar I
would say scholar library on top of
Google Cloud which is a Java and Python
so and then we have the scheduler like
sticks is scheduler in workers on and
kubernetes and so forth so we have like
we continue our code and then we
schedule a code on a gulet loud and
definitely as we said data Prague is
there is a main tool we are using and of
course pretty much everything ends up on
bigquery or data storage because
bigquery is super strong and then we can
just query like any other data
warehouses thank you very much and if
you have any question
[Applause]
okay thanks a lot for the nice talk I
just wanted to ask you to use any kind
of tool to programmatically deploy the
cluster infrastructure yeah actually we
we created something ourselves so when
because in the beginning even Google
didn't have this one if you run a
cluster imagine if you forget or if
maybe your code takes forever you go
home and the day after the cost will be
super mad so then we created a tool in
order to to see if there is a limit or
if maybe after two hours
try to destroy the cluster so we created
that and now also Google has something
extra then you can put some limit if the
cluster is not running anything just
destroy it after 5 minutes or after any
minutes you want but definitely yes we
have we have some tools and is that one
is based on Apache Luigi that's also an
Orchestrator from spotify so buy with
that Orchestrator we spin up the cluster
and then a cluster is a dependency to
the job and then the job will run after
the job is finished our tool will
destroy the cluster so then everything
is kind of orchestrated with Luigi yeah
thank you so you think back basically
you did no spark knowledge so you can
integrate the code of profit like it's
plug-and-play
how do you integrate it like some
user-defined function or actually that's
it that's it that's a piu because we
create a library that at that library
automatically when you get your model as
just a typical function so with that one
we paralyze and then let's say that you
want to run your model hundred times
with hundred different sets of
parameters so under the hood we created
a library to paralyze all of these and
then what you need to do as a programmer
or as a data scientist just create your
function input is pandas dataframe
output is pandas dataframe and the rest
will be handled with the code that we
created is not I would say is it could
be is not like a typical user-defined
ud is not a typical UDF but is there are
some quotes that they are there handling
all of these but so you still have to go
through some kind of serialization to go
back to the spark um yeah and execute
the psychical interface so you are going
up and down from profit to again it does
but but the main thing is if you have
some aggregation later on because when
spin-ups like all of these tasks so they
run like of course there are
civilizations but of and that they are
gonna run independently from each other
and they have nothing else to do with
each other
but in the end the main thing is if we
get all of these forecasts down to the
one place and then the biggest challenge
is how to aggregate that one and then
that's gonna be the heavy serialization
or heavy aggregation on spark but the
rest is super simple because each task
can take like less than a second run on
this big cluster hi how do you deal with
forecast with time series with without
as much history historical data and so
deal with for example and anomalies
between your data so actually this is
one of the way that we forecast time
series we have different tools and some
of the tools even we don't have time
series to forecast we have some cohort
retention data in order to forecast so
if there are some egg markets that they
are like recently launched so our way of
forecasting is totally different it's
not profit or it's not like a typical
time series because if you have three
months of data it is not possible to
forecast the next two years but but we
have a lot of mature markets that we are
going to forecast them in this way and
other ways and we are going to compare
them together we are going to score and
then for some cases we know that profit
chimes and for other cases we know that
our built in logics otherwise they will
be they are way better but definitely
for small data or for small market that
is not possible
yes in this case yes but we there there
are some works in order to try to mix
them together because it's not really
like that because when it comes to
streams so we have the different
products and some of the products are
super super tiny
so we then we have to kind of combine
them together we have to round some data
and then we are going to forecast those
so I would say yes I know but in this
case in this talk I was trying to say
that everything will be independent but
in reality no it's not like that yeah so
do you so the profit configuration for
each time series like seasonality or you
know the change points yeah where do you
store that to where do I store the
transport yeah so like do you sort of
for each individual series do you sort
of have profit configurations actually
we don't for each individual city we
don't say that okay let's run with these
configurations yeah however how we say
is okay these are the range for prior
scale for number of change point or for
anything else so we have a lot of ranges
for all the time series we try to run
all of them together so it's not like
for one country we run to range for the
other country we run something else no
then we try to run for all of them but
what you are saying is maybe more
advanced maybe we can try to even make
it like very specific for each country
yes a Christmas songs are seasonal oh
sorry see something like Christmas songs
so but but as I said also default is
what we do what we do for most of them
okay because because is super heavy we
cannot do that so your configuration is
by country yeah it is by country after a
while because we know for some of the
countries that these are the
configurations so we kind of cheat
because because we ran it many many
times we know that for some of them
these are hard-coded so we are not going
to try
all of these things together but for the
other ones we are going to try every
maybe every quarter in order to find out
what is going on okay thanks yeah thanks
we're running out of time please bring
other questions offline so thanks my
home again
[Applause]